Salut à tous c’est Pêcheur de Trésors
Aujourd'hui nouvelle vidéo avec Wim
Vous l'avez reconnu.
Avec Danny,
on est de retour sur le fameux spot.
Ou on a trouvé un coffre fort, des cadres de scooters
et une multitude de choses.
Aujourd'hui, ce qu'on va faire, c'est
qu'on va pêcher à l'aimant
mais on va pêcher avec des perches
et on va essayer de récupérer
tout ce qu'il y a au fond de l'eau.
Et qui n'est pas venu
quand on a jeté nos aimants
avec la corde, Quentin est au travail.
Mais il va nous rejoindre
d'ici une petite heure,
donc on va commencer sans lui et on verra
si on arrive à lui montrer
ce qu'on a trouvé.
Bien sûr, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
et de regarder la chaîne de Wim,
qui a lancé sa nouvelle chaîne YouTube et
qui fait déjà de très belles découvertes.
Donc, il pêche surtout aux Pays-Bas,
mais il est aussi allé en Belgique
et commence à faire des roadtrip
Il est en France
pour quelques jours avec Danny Boy.
Un petit dernier mot à dire en français
avant de commencer ?
Un dernier mot en français ?
J’ai un bijou
Je pense aussi qu’il faut regarder sous le pont
Une main de Fatma, surement un bijou arabe
C’est bon signe
Parce qu’il y avait des coffre-forts ici
Je pense aussi
Vous cherchez quoi ?
Des trésors
Ils ressemblent à quoi les trésors ?
En fait, on utilise des aimants puissants
au bout d'une perche
et il y a de tout.
Il y a des bouts de voiture,
un coffre fort, un coffre fort
parce qu'ils sont cambriolés, jetés.
Mais ils étaient vides.
Ceux là étaient vide, mais des fois,
ils laissent quelques indices.
C'est l'aventure
Vous ne mettez pas la tête dans l'eau quand même
Lui il le fait
Mais pas vous.
J'aime pas trop, elle n'a pas bon gout
C'est le canal du Midi ?
Non, c'est un autre petit canal, c'est
un autre canal.
Mais l'eau, elle rentre dans votre combinaison ?
Ouais
Il faudra une bonne douche
Ah oui,
ah oui.
Avec Danny on est en train de faire sous le pont.
Parce que c'est vrai qu'on avait sorti des coffres forts ici.
Donc ce qu'on va faire,
c'est qu'on va essayer de voir s'il
n'y avait pas de choses dedans.
Il y a quand même énormément de vase
Wil qui enchaîne les panneaux
Il vient de faire un panneau
"No kill carnassier"
C'est vrai
qu'il y a pas mal de poissons ici.
Les pêcheurs seront contents
qu'on ait nettoyé tout ça, j'espère.
Là, on est sur la partie du pont
qu'on avait déjà fait
dans la précédente vidéo
et vous avez bien apprécié.
Donc on continue cette partie là
jusqu'à ce que Quentin arrive
Quand il arrive on passe de l'autre côté du pont.
Il y avait aussi pas mal de coffres forts
et là, viens de voir ça
qui flottait à la surface.
Donc c'est un petit os.
Encore fois, j'espère
que ce n'est pas un os humain
T’as eu quoi ?
Une montre de poche
Une montre à gousset
Jolie !
Magnifique !
Bravo
Un couteau
Alors, qu'est ce qu'on a ici ?
Une clé
Elle est dans un sale état.
ça commence super bien avec la montre.
Elle est magnifique et un couteau.
Un volant
Vous ne venez pas ??
Ce n'est pas très agréable
Dany viens, viens
Regarde c’est bien
Quand tu es sorti
Je suis presque dehors
Maintenant il faut faire des vagues
Pauvre Dany
Il tient son aimant comme une lance
On est de l’autre côté, on va essayer ici
Il y avait aussi des coffres forts, ça devrait être fun
Il y a quelque chose à l’intérieur
C’est un sac
un caillou
C’est une brique ou quoi ?
Oui c’est fermé
C’est une sorte de pierre
Un fusil ?
Est-ce que c'est un bout de canon ?
C’est bizarre
C'est très bizarre
Peut être qu'il a été rempli de béton.
Si quelqu'un reconnait, dites le nous en commentaire
Si vous savez.
C’est pour enrouler du câble
Oh un sac
Qu’est-ce qu’il y a dans ce sac ?
Pour une voiture
Une clé en croix
Une plaque d'immatriculation
C’est une ancienne
Elles étaient comme ça, jaunes comme la votre
Donc c’est une ancienne
Oui
La criminalité
On est du bon côté du pont
Ici on a déjà trouvé un gyrophare de police
Un petit sac
Ah non il n’y a rien
Mais aussi du calibre 12
Et une pièce
Une munition non ?
Ah non non non
Mais 5 centimes
Un vélo !
J'ai peut être quelque chose, enfin
accroché à l'aimant.
Je vais essayer de voir si ça vient.
Une sorte de ressort cassé
peut être un sofa.
Une bouteille de vin qui est sortie d'un coup.
J'ai une pièce aussi.
Wow !
Un franc en 1974.
Le premier d’un million
Wim a quelque chose
Qu'est ce que c'est que ça ?
OK, une autre pièce
OK, ok.
Du franc, encore
0,50€ de franc je pense.
C’est pour couper dans les angles
Un sac ?
J'ai un sac
Ils ont utilisé des pierres
Pour le lester
Je pense qu’ils ont volé des vêtements
Oh regarde, regarde
C’est volé
J’enlève l’aimant
Ok c’est intéressant
On est au bon endroit pour trouver ces choses
Je ne sais pas ce que c’est
Ca vient seulement d'une voiture, ça.
Dites nous en commentaires si vous savez
Et encore des cintres
et des antivols.
OK, je viens de remonter ça
avec le triangle.
Pas mal.
Automotive division.
Ok j’ai un truc
Vous êtes prets ?
J’aime la forme
C’est une boîte
Avec quelque chose à l’intérieur
Peut-être une pierre
On va vérifier
C’est toujours bien de trouver des boîtes
Il y a une pierre à l’intérieur
Qu’est-ce qu’il y a dans la boîte ?
Seulement le caillou pour que ça coule
Je n’aime pas la forme de ce truc
Et je n’aime pas le poids de ce truc
Je pense que c’est ce dont je te parlais
Ce que vous avez dans votre garage
Regarde
Tu sais que ça coûte très chère quand ça fait cette taille
ça coûte très chère
On va le mettre dans le riz
Pas celui-là
ça pèse son petit poids ce truc
Il y a Quentin
Oh yes il a pris à manger !
Regarde Rasta
Du cuivre
Je viens de les rejoindre sur le spot,
je suis tout propre
Je ne sais pas si je me change
ou si je viens comme ça
Tu me conseille quoi ?
Je te conseille de ne pas venir, ça pue.
On va manger d'abord, petite pause
Tu as quelque chose ?
Une machine à café !
Il y a des choses étranges ici
Poses la guitare
On a prit la guitare pour faire une Storie Instagram
Si vous l'avez vu, vous êtes les meilleurs
Oh, un sac !
C'est un parapluie
Ah non, c'est un sac
Ça, c'est un antivol
un bloque volant de voiture
Il y a quelque chose dans le sac
peut-être que tu devrais l’ouvrir hors de l’eau
Ne bouge pas je te nettoies
Baisse toi baisse toi
Mets ta tête dans l’eau
Tu as l’oreille remplie
Maintenant il faut qu’on parle plus fort !
DANYYYY DANNNYYYY
Je crois que j'ai un coffre fort
Je vais devoir mettre ma bouche dans l'eau
C’est ok ça vient
Une batterie !
C’est bien de la sortir !
C'est une batterie de voiture
Ok, sympa
Un sac
Il est fermé
Vous pouvez ouvrir les deux en même temps
Donc c’était aimanté ?
On va là bas pour l’ouvrir ?
DANYYYY
Voyons voir ce qu'il y a dans le sac
C’est une photo
ça vient d’un polaroid
Je vais la nettoyer
Des sangles, c’est bien pour la pêche à l’aimant
On va la nettoyer
Si vous reconnaissez cette personne.
Dans le sud de la France.
Ok, le sac est vidé
Une carte d'identité
On doit pouvoir lire quelque chose
"Magasin et bureau"
Rasta, laisse le chien.
Laisse le
Rasta !
Eh bien ok.
Viens !
C'est bien
Il n’y a rien de plus
Mais ça vient d’un magasin
Une cassette
Vous appelez ça une cassette vous aussi ?
Comme en français
Une boite
Maintenant on va passer à l'ouverture du second sac
Ok une pierre
Une carte bleue
On va la nettoyer après
Il y a surement un nom là dessus
On peut nettoyer avec un seau d’eau
Dommage, juste des papiers
Quentin nous a rejoint et il va tester la pêche à la perche
J'ai ressorti le vieux aimant Beast avec lequel je pêchais il y a 3 ans
On va voir ce que ça donne
Allé, dans l'eau
Franchement je suis excité
J'ai envie de tester ça
pour ceux qui se le demande.
Nos perches et nos aimants viennent du site de Maison
de la détection.
Ils ont toute une gamme d'aimants complète.
Mais nous, en général,
on recommande les aimants 360 degrés.
Le Terror est idéal pour débuter,
mais aujourd'hui,
on pêche avec la gamme de dessus,
l'aimant Beast
Et l'aimant Barbarian de 1400 à 1600 kilos respectivement.
Vous avez toutes les infos en description
et le code promo Pêcheur de Trésor
qui offre 5% sur toute la boutique
ça vient
ça vient d’une mobylette
Oh oui, j'ai eu quelque chose
Ma première découverte
Ma première trouvaille, une pince
Elle est coincée
Pour la cuisine
C’est une hotte aspirante
C’est dangereux ça
Un morceau de voiture
Belle trouvaille
C’est bien de la sortir de l’eau
Tu nous le sort ?
Encore une
Deuxième bleue.
Une grille d'aération.
Je viens de trouver une pièce
Pour les pièces, c'est bien comme technique.
1996, 0,05€ de francs.
On a des clés,
Un porte clef avec une autre clef ici
Intéressant
Est-ce qu'il y a écrit quelque chose ?
Un nom
Une autre
Il n'y a plus de rayon
Bien joué
Là j'ai quelque chose
ça reste quelque chose
C’est une mine
C'est un disque de frein
Regardez ce que Wim vient de trouver
Une grosse enceinte
Il y a un gros aimant
Tu peux t’en servir
Oui tu peux essayer
Mais je prefère garder mon propre aimant
Regardez la moule
Une énorme moule de rivière
Une anodonte
Est-ce qu’il y a une perle à l’intérieur ?
Oh non, elle est vide
On change de spot ?
On change d’endroit ?
Ok parfait
Il va juste me falloir 50 minutes pour arriver jusqu’à toi
On va voir si Quentin se débrouille
pour arriver en marchant vite.
Allez,
Oh. Il a triché.
Il y a trop d'algues
La pêche a été bonne !
Pas mal.
Dire que nous on pêche ici ...
Vous perdez des leurres un peu ?
Ouais
Vous en perdrez moins.
Une batterie de voiture et tout
C'est la pêche à l'aimant ?
Ouais, c'est ça.
Félicitations en tout cas les gars
Merci
Au revoir
Regardez les trois hommes torses nus devant
On est mieux derrière avec Rasta.